When you create a list.
Like could it up here?
You are indirectly creating.
an object
a dictionary is an object.
So in other words when you create a list in Python,
you are indirectly creating the
dictionary. So behind the scenes, let's say
python will do the following.
So remember in a dictionary you must have the keys, right?
and the key can either be a number or
a string
when you create a list you're actually doing that indirectly.
so here
the indices are no longer applied.
But they are explicitly.
captain
now just keep in mind. I'm going to
refer to some class terminology.
If you're watching this later and you this is
a this is too fast for you. Like I said, just watch the playlist, okay?
I'm just
Quickly reviewing some python topics for
later, but if you want a full tutorial it exists, so
don't worry.
Let me bring back the airports.
These four data structures that we talked about very quickly.
So we have
lists
two poles
sets
dictionaries
these are all instances of a
class.
So let me use.
A functions as a stepping stone for understanding classes.
Okay.
So what is a function let's create a third section
of fourth.
A third section, right?
So the data structures
Let's do functions.
And then we'll do classes.
a function is a collection of
programming statements
Okay. So let's say you have one statement here print price like
we did in the initial example.
Then you have some variable
called sum or not. We can't use that.
Let's say the sum and that is equal to number A
Plus number B.
And then let's see up here. We have two variables in there
a equals 10.
Would be equals 20 whatever right?
These are I'm just trying to typing some random lines here.
So that's a statement. That's a statement is all statements.
Put them inside.
This detected together if you
want to contain them together if you want them to be associated with each other
you can.
You indent your code?
So you can put them inside a function.
Okay.
But indentation spacing rather
is everything in Python.
So let's say you have a function if you want to create a
function you type in the reserved keyword Def.
And you can see in vs code. This is indicated by
the color.
And then you would type in this for example some function.
Okay, that's how you
Declare a function name.
now functions have scope
right a function is a collection of instructions. So let's say
these are the instructions that we want to put inside the function.
So you do is you
Come up here. And then you
push push the code inside
just like that you have put these five times of code
inside the function. So this is outside the function inside the
function outside the function inside the function. That's it.
now
this function is actually doing anything particularly useful, but I just
want to show you how to how you create a function.
So if a function is a collection of statements.
If a function is a collection of statements.
then a class is a collection of
fill in the blacks
so class is a collection of functions.
How do you create a class?
like so
let's say class.
And I want to use something that is not so abstract. Let's call
it car.
You notice something here.
The Declaration is very similar.
Here, we have a reserved keyword followed by a name and
a pair of parentheses. And of course, ah colon which
indicates the scope is going to be a scope same
thing with classes. We have our reserved keyword followed by
a name Perth sees and the calling
which indicates the scope.
Now you want to pay attention to something if you notice I
may see uppercase.
This is not mistake, and it's not arbitrary.
The only time you're allowed to declare a function, excuse me,
the only time we're allowed to
use an uppercase letter is when you're declaring classes when you
declare variables.
And functions you must always use
lowercase letters.
The very first letter must be all lowercase.
Your code will not break if you violate this rule this
convention, but it is a very bad practice.
It will confuse others who look at your script and perhaps even
yourself when you come back to your code later on.
So always use lowercase.
For the first character unless you're defining
a class.
So we said that a class as well. We said that we said that it
is a collection of functions. So what are some of the functions of a car?
What are the things that car can do it can accelerate?
Okay.
And it does something. Let me just put some code in here.
It can break.
And let's type in some fixed statements in here.
Reverse or whatever, right?
And I'm just gonna put the return keyword so that I don't
get these linking. I don't
get these linking in and my code so
Exactly, right. So we have some programming statements
and the function returns something.
Programming statements that you turn something programming statements
and it turns something now notice how I've used the invitation
to indicate the scope of this function.
Same thing here. Same thing here.
and of course all three functions
Are indented indicating that all three functions belong inside
the class.
so
there you have it. We said a function is a collection
of statements and a class the collection of functions. There's there's
more
First of all, when you put a function inside a class,
we don't call it a function anymore.
There's a special name.
If you put a function inside of class, it's still a function. Well, we
just give it a different name to make it especially clear.
That this function can only work.
When the class is involved or rather when the object is instantiated
anyone know what we call functions when they're inside
a class.
Precisely methods, right?